[Music]
[Applause]
very well the contract has been sealed
let's begin the challenge of strata dude
today we have the sports edition of
scattered fluid that's right
sports are so funny i can't stop
laughing
so i was just thinking about sports
let's uh do a sport edition of
scattered fluid that's a definitely a
good idea
jesus
oh my god damn women don't play around
that is not scratha that's concern
meanwhile men playing football
why is football known as soccer just a
lamer sport of all time thanks to this
sort of things sports is just so stupid
does anyone actually watch
sport unironically you know how old
people are always like why would you
watch someone else play a video game
why would you watch sports then that's
like 10 times worse
i don't get it
[Music]
what am i supposed to do then huh he
became a bar
damn wrestling sure is tough this is
literally me
anytime i get in a fight with someone
caption
me as the ball and the wrestler as my
responsibilities
and you got yourself an epic tumblr gif
right there
oh i almost got that sorry
sorry i was just thinking about gifs
gifts
i thought about gifts so funny they just
make me laugh
almost as funny as sports is all of
these without sound like what the heck
oh
zero three oh here comes the tears
oh no my team is losing
it keeps happening
[Music]
oh yes
zero five zero six
when did this happen jesus
oh my god you're crying
pathetic oh my god
why are they crying you don't get it man
you just don't care about sports
i guess i don't jesus christ pathetic
all right this sports idea clearly isn't
worth it
and i'm just gonna get a lot of hate
from you scumbags who think sports is
cool
i bet you i can beat you in any sports
i'll have you know i'm extremely
athletic
um cuckold a cuckold is a man
whose wife is promiscuous to his face
and everybody knows it
exactly exactly um in in this particular
scene
and this is a genre of film uh yeah yeah
a very popular genre
um i've like i said i've done several of
these and you play the cuckold
i was just recognized for an award at
the avn awards for best uh uh
cuckhold um uh film and uh
in this particular scene my wife is uh
shaming who now who plays your wife oh
my actual wife
that's debbie yeah you can't see with
you can't see your entire face he's he's
a pretty
big guy wait a minute there's an
african-american man
that can't be real that must have been a
sketch that's so good
have you scrapped that yet let me know
in the comments right now
maybe the sport bit was a bit too much
for you i know
we have some pretty funny clips here and
basically the new ray william johnson
but at least i don't throw a black baby
around that bit was hilarious
oh you don't believe me i just want to
take a baby
who happens to be black and throw it
now guys and you'll be like snuggling
him every morning and be like oh it's so
cute
but no and that's it uh me and uh
listerine here we'll see you in a few
days
sive is editing right now and he's
literally shaking in anger i know
side this is some pretty outrageous
racism can't believe it
from my favorite youtuber william
johnson
who inspired me to create this show
myself by laughing at funny clips
i love it i just love it i mean i hate
it it's upsetting that's what i meant
sorry i got it all mixed up
[Music]
okay all right you talking to me welcome
back to adventure call where we rejoin
stevie
on line two oh i didn't recognize him do
you realize steven that you're on the
verge of being the first traveller
to find a black ruby of all the side all
right can we just go
meet me very well
i bet brad brad is so into dnd
he would love this hi everybody it's me
brad woto
we started a d d sort of collaborative
effort
[Music]
just to suffer you actually helped me
tell you to get the wing sandals and you
left them behind without warning me
just to prove a point i didn't warn you
i did warn
i feel like brad would appreciate this
one
sports and dnd they're equally bad
that's that's just how it is
great plan b
this is for everyone you've killed a
lead murderer
hold your fire this man isn't black
sorry next clip everyone rick
i've really got to go pee where can i go
oh don't worry you cute little morty
head morty
i'll take you to the bush dimension you
can pee behind a tree there
this is australian rick and morty we're
in the bloody bush dimension
it could be here go behind that tree
there morty that one
that tree do it yay morty yay
okay don't look
oh a snake bit me what
a snake be my penis rich oh no i've got
to suck your penis
morty i've got to suck your little morty
penis to get the venom out now
what but you're my granddad oh come on
morty just one
little sock you'll save your lauren rick
and morty summarize everyone
there you go fantastic is this official
it has the adult swim on it that's
awesome
if it is
[Music]
hey
uh
[Applause]
what in the world i feel like someone's
going to explain
it in the comments and they're going to
be like excuse me felix she's suffering
from
bell blue and i can't believe you're so
insensitive like what am i
what is this i don't know they're
speaking crazy language
eastern european countries are so weird
you don't know what's happening
is it edited
let's watch that one again this is what
just one more quick little watch
i feel like i'm going crazy i don't i
can't
i can't explain but i don't want to see
that ever again
good motor good voter
good motor good voter it sounds healthy
get us to the island
it sounds to be stalling hurry up
take it even further
[Applause]
fine okay fine you made me chuckle what
do you want
what jesus christ
[Applause]
jesus christ
jesus it's terrifying
oh thank god
great i feel like now i know how i'm
going to die
look good
now i know how i'm going to die
why are we still here
just to suffer that is
genuinely terrifying open this in 20
[Music]
tabs
screw it i'm gonna do it i don't care
about the consequences
okay oh my god
are you ready
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yes oh
yes
[Music]
what um happening i'm scared and
confused this whole episode
it started off with sports what is
[Music]
happening
i don't want any more nightmares please
god damn it that's it for this weeks
it was a wide range of emotions but we
made it through everybody
so make sure you leave a like if you
stopped and i like you feel for laura
and i will see you next time
goodbye